I'll just put it in my butt it's up my
ass oh my god oh you know this about me
their Roman Empire I.E the random things
they're always thinking about um lunch
yes like lunch first of all miles always
knows what's next she always just just
like we're going to get out here at 6
because we got four more of the I'd be
like damn I don't even notice but we
always I'll just put in my butt it's up
my ass oh my God it was it up there
before it was up there and I was holding
it just release you the random thing
you're always thinking about you're
always singing in your head and you
don't even realize it so I feel like
lyrics music notes I'm always making up
little songs MH